If you've ever been in that situation, psychologists would suggest that you not
helping the person was due to what we term diffusion of responsibility. And
this just states that when many people are present, we are less likely to help.
Now, I mentioned earlier that, in addition to this research, many researchers
have looked at bystander effect. And they have found that there are some
variables that actually influence whether we are more likely or less likely to
help, besides just the number of people present. Some of the variables and
situations they looked at in regards to bystander effect and diffusion of
responsibility. Have been emergencies versus non-emergencies. They've looked at
the ambiguity and consequences of the situation. They've looked at priming by
the bystander. So for example, the bystander may attempt to get eye contact
with a participant. They've also looked at cohesiveness and group membership.
And finally they looked at personality and background. There are lots of
studies on the bystander effect, but now let's go back to Lauren and talk a
little bit more about how we assess whether or not we should get involved.